[Música]
el lanzamiento de treats la nueva red
social de meta que se asemeja a Twitter
ha sido recibida por un gran una gran
cantidad de usuarios como una verdadera
alternativa al pájaro azul que
recientemente ha despertado el
descontento de los internautas debido a
las crecientes restricciones sin embargo
meta propietaria de Facebook no ha
estado libre de pecados Pues lleva
cuestas un turbulento historial
relacionado con la privacidad la
filtración de datos y escándalos por la
difusión de información falsa vamos a
analizar este tema y por ello saludamos
a Ariel correatelli él es experto en
tecnología y consultor de tecnologías de
la información Ariel Bienvenido a
directo América
Hola qué tal Buenos días y muchas
gracias por la invitación las cifras
hablan por sí solas son 30 millones de
suscripciones en tan solo dos días no
podemos reconocer o desconocer la
sensación que ha tenido
su descenso tan rápido como su ascenso o
qué posibilidades reales tiene de
arrebatarle ese lugar a Twitter
yo creo que realmente están en un
momento óptimo y creo que Mark
Zuckerberg hizo una excelentísima jugada
porque está digamos este juntando los
dos mundos el mundo de Instagram y el
mundo de Twitter de alguna forma
inclusive hace muchísima alusión a
twitters en todo sentido en el día de
ayer el mismísimo Marc después de 11
años de no tuitear O sea de no publicar
nada en la red social de Twitter
digamos público un meme con un
spider-man donde bueno se muestra
en uno al lado del otro no y yo creo que
realmente es una una muy buena opción
digamos este y además este todo lo que
está utilizando creo que que es
excelente o sea en principio tenemos un
día digamos de de uso de la red y la
verdad que tuvo una aceptación muy muy
grande
no O sea creo que es es una es una buena
opción es una una buena herramienta
además ahora como lo decíamos
anteriormente la reputación de meta
tampoco es la mejor en medio de estas
controversias por filtración de datos Y
también por cuestiones de privacidad
como esto podría afectar la confianza de
los usuarios en esta nueva red social
Yo creo que la mayoría de las personas
es como que
utilizan Instagram y Y de cualquier
forma está totalmente ligada
está totalmente ligada a Instagram
inclusive Si queremos una vez que
activamos desde nuestro perfil que
activamos este tres automáticamente ya
no lo podemos eliminar entonces con lo
cual está ligado Y si queremos salir de
Twitch lo que tenemos que hacer es
eliminar Instagram así que por ese lado
quizás está un poco un poco complicado
una de las opciones por si alguno se
arrepienten algún momento porque ha
habido muchos comentarios al respecto
una de las este opciones Es que la
pongan la cuenta en privada o sea se
puede poner en privado y bueno
obviamente existe el usuario de tweet
que es el mismo de Instagram y bueno de
alguna forma no estaría funcionando y en
relación al de privacidad sí es cierto
yo siempre creo que digo lo mismo desde
que entramos al Siglo 21 es como que la
privacidad en internet la hemos perdido
o sea creo que eso es yo creo que todo
el mundo lo tiene que asumir la hemos
perdido en todo sentido porque si no es
Facebook en su momento meta ahora
también Google o sea siempre digamos
este estamos ahí latentes en cuanto a la
privacidad o sea lo veo lo veo difícil
lo veo difícil y cada vez más incisivo
con el tema del uso de las redes
sociales no las redes sociales sino la
Inteligencia artificial que a veces ves
más incisivo al tema de la privacidad a
propósito de lo que usted mencionaba
hace un momento precisamente ya hay
quejas de los usuarios en redes sociales
cuando se dieron cuenta que
efectivamente no podían eliminar la
cuenta de tweets sino eliminaban la
cuenta de Instagram y es precisamente un
llamado a leer la letra pequeña qué
responsabilidad recae en nosotros los
usuarios a la hora de suscribirnos a una
nueva red social como esta
y yo creo que el problema que tenemos la
gran mayoría de usuarios es que nunca
leemos la letra chica o sea nunca leemos
la letra chica y y automáticamente
aceptamos todo y bueno o sea sucede
y digamos lo único que les puedo decir
si es que no cambia el tema de el tema
de esta restricción que es cierto que
que ha sucedido es la única opción que
tenemos es si lo habilitamos y estamos
desconforme con utilizarlo Bueno lo
podemos poner la cuenta en privada y
bueno no utilizarla no utilizarla más
este pero de vuelta si ya tenemos una
cuenta en instagram la privacidad de
alguna forma la hemos perdido
Entonces esto como algo más de última no
utilicemos este
no lo utilicemos y y bueno sigamos
usando Instagram como como lo veníamos
haciendo hasta el momento creo que que
por ese lado pasa es como que lo medio o
sea medio complicado y medio como como
decir quejoso no inclusive también lo lo
que mencionaba antes el tema de
de las restricciones que se dieron en
Twitter el sábado pasado y que generó un
montón de revuelo y la realidad es que
son servicios esto hay que yo creo que
hay que tenerlo siempre en cuenta que
son servicios gratuitos no estamos
pagando por los servicios Entonces estos
son los dueños y ellos pueden hacer lo
que quieran con el servicio podemos
estar de acuerdo o no podemos estar de
acuerdo podemos darle más a Facebook
podemos dar de baja Instagram podemos
dar de baja Twitter lo podemos hacer
Bueno creo que esas es nuestra única
opción si estamos de conforme O sea no
es que esté a favor de las empresas que
hacen este tipo cosas Yo creo que no
está bueno pero creo que todas las
empresas están haciendo Exactamente lo
mismo que hace lo mismo Bueno entonces
es como que
no tenemos muchas herramientas y estamos
en internet es como que ya no existe
mucha privacidad ya estamos en internet
Ariel debemos recordar también que por
ejemplo Twitch no es la única que ha
intentado competir con Twitter lo han
hecho en el pasado 38 por ejemplo
también que es la la red social de
Donald Trump sin embargo ninguna de
ellas ha tenido este éxito que se
esperaba hay que tener en cuenta que
está respaldada por la inmensa
maquinaria que tiene meta en qué medida
esto Es bueno o malo
yo creo que a ver creo que es bueno a mí
sinceramente lo veo con con buenos ojos
o sea o sea entiendo el tema de la
privacidad Totalmente de acuerdo con eso
pero creo que es es bueno lo hizo muy
bien y de hecho no sé si si lo han leído
ayer pero digamos este el mismo el
mismísimo y lo más le está iniciando
acciones legales a meta porque
supuestamente lo que hizo y lo que hizo
meta es contratar ex empleados de
Twitter y fueron los que en pocos meses
desarrollaron la red social nueva de
meta esto es un poco lo que se dio a
entender veremos cómo avanza Esto fue
fue ayer y Y si empezamos a ver un poco
hilar más a fondo cómo funciona y sí
tiene muchas cosas que realmente uno lo
ve como Twitter inclusive una de las
funciones cuando uno publica un hilo da
la opción de digamos este de compartir y
es una opción de compartir que dice
tuitear así tal cual dice tuitear y
cuando hago clic en tuitean esa
publicación la manta a Twitter o sea
como un tuitch entonces bueno si tiene
tiene algo de razón y con respecto a a
true la la red de Donald Trump Bueno
creo que no no tiene tanto tanto vuelo
lo que sí podríamos hablar de
de Twitter y que no vio la oportunidad
de hecho sigue siendo con invitación
privada Y entonces es como que tampoco
dio el vuelo Así que yo creo que yo creo
que que va va calar muy hondo en la
gente de hecho se está notando que que
muchísimas personas se han sumado y hay
una actividad terrible esperemos que no
venga sesgada con todo la toxicidad de
alguna forma que fue generando Twitter
durante tanto tiempo